and he did not recant that information
if you had the chance to ask a question
would that be your question or is there
something else you want to hear from the
ambassador
uh something else i'd ask her if she's
aware that jeffrey epstein didn't kill
himself
we'll go on next to uh chad joining us
from michigan our line for independence
good morning chad
good morning i am calling from the upper
peninsula of michigan so i want to say
hi to my youtubers
my comment today is it's kind of a
question for congress i'm just wondering
if we are so worried about the hearsay
evidence and everything happening where
it's this is emotion this is hearsay
then why are we not allowing the people
who have first-hand knowledge and direct
knowledge of these happenings to testify
the fact that these people are being
blocked from testifying and are ignoring
their subpoenas or waiting for another
department to verify their subpoenas to
allow to come forward is just a bad look
i believe if there was evidence that
would
show that the president is not acting
against current u.s foreign policy and
is not going for his own personal
beliefs that evidence would have come
out
thank you for the call if you're just
tuning in wondering what's happening the
house is in
session right now live coverage on
c-span with a series of votes expected
to go probably another 10 to 15 maybe 20
minutes and so we are monitoring that
during the break of the house
intelligence committee we're using this
opportunity to share with you some of
the highlights of course all of it on
our website at csbn.org and if you're
listening on the free c-span radio app
burma is joining us miami florida
democrats line go ahead please
hi um i am very proud of ambassador
yavanovic i am so happy that she came
forward
i see that she's been honest about her
experience and all of what she's gone
through
i am just befuddled by the republican
insistence on ignoring
the obvious bribery
and extortion attempt of donald trump
i cannot i'm so disheartened
by what i am seeing
from the republican party who's supposed
to be the party of law and order
i voted
for ronald reagan
i am so
disappointed
and i hope that real
republicans step forward and
help the people that are just following
blindly
and standing behind
this president
and the republican party
in congress what they're doing is so
wrong for
our government
this should not be happening this is not
russia
thank you for the call we've been also
monitoring in a dc courtroom at the
trial of roger stone a longtime aide and
friend among others facing charges of
perjury and we learned just a moment ago
that roger stone has been found guilty
this again from reuters that trump
advisor roger stone found guilty of
obstruction as well as making false
statements that news breaking at this
hour as we approach noon eastern time
here in washington dc on capitol hill
roger stone found guilty on charges of
obstruction and perjury
next is kathleen joining us from lake
worth florida go ahead
yes um yes i was
just calling to ask are they serving for
the president at the service of the
president that way she did this
and if she did isn't she breaking an
oath of office
by not
um supporting the president
and it seems like there's an awful lot
of emotional stuff going on
and
do we really want our
ambassadors to act like that
i'm sorry but if she's serving for
under the president but these these
people are really breaking the road by
even having this
conversation
so you don't find her credible is that
is that safe to say
i uh but what i find about her is that
she's very emotional and i think the
president was right in saying that
she has a lot of issues going on there's
issues with her
thank you for the call we'll go to eli
he's joining us from mooresville north
carolina independent good morning
good morning
so i believe that this whole impeachment
trial is very interesting as we haven't
really seen anything like this since the
bill clinton administration uh and i
think it's really we don't know
everything about what's happening with
ukraine however i do think with the
current state of events
that there is a lot of evidence against
them but i guess the real question is
why were the cameras turned off in fcsl
the president this morning saying that
the democrats must apologize to the usa
saying that the ukrainian foreign
minister said that u.s ambassador gordon
sutherland did not link it's disgusting
it's absolutely not representative of
the will of the people the people voted
differently all right craig we're going
to go on to our republican line next and
hear from tim in arnold arnold maryland
go ahead tim
hi there
hey tim go ahead i think hi i think
there's two real takeaways at today's
hearing that we can have one i think
that steve casterfella is really doing
us no favors he seems like a real dingus
and two uh jeffrey epstein clearly
killed himself back to you
all right here's kathleen in uh good
guide guilderland new york kathleen's on
the we want to try to do something going
long term that's been untenable in a
divided congress
michael in austin texas and independent
hello uh good morning uh thank you for
taking my call uh it's a little bit
about myself i'm a student texas state
university i do a lot of the work in the
student government and um
the general consensus that we see here
at the university about issues like that
especially as like the younger people
we will be carrying over the steps that
we are inheriting basically through even
though we might not benefit might not be
benefiting from a lot of the stuff
that's happening the general consensus
is that jeffrey epstein didn't kill
himself
we're going to move on shafi in canton
ohio democratic caller sophie good
morning
yes i'm
off the subject but i would like to see
that hot white house
to grow up and good quick strive to come
from a place of love and not react in
the same way of those who are against
what we are building in this country
this is about building a just and
equitable future for my two boys
children across the country and future
generations
back to your phone calls patricia in
minneapolis go ahead please
yeah uh you forgot to mention that um
bloomberg donated over 300 000 to the
dnc right before they made that change
in the rules and then also
when are you going to have a show on
representative ilhan omar committing um
immigration fraud by marrying her
brother
and jeffrey epstein didn't kill himself
patricia we'll leave it there thank you
for the call we'll go to les in page
arizona go ahead please
hello thanks for taking the call
i'm an independent and uh